spokesperson for Kia stahma the Labour
leader has issued this statement this
relates to his education shadow
education secretary Rebecca long Bailey
also a contender for the Labour Party
leadership seen as the natural successor
to Jeremy Corbyn by Jeremy Corbyn
supporters at least the statement reads
this afternoon Chioma asked Rebecca long
Bailey to step down from the Shadow
Cabinet the article
Rebecca shared earlier today contained
an anti-semitic conspiracy theory this
we think concerns an article if not
written by then quoting a well-known
actor we'll get more on that for you
later on as leader of the Labour Party
Kier has been clear the restoring trust
with the Jewish community is a
number-one priority anti-semitism takes
many different forms and it's important
that we're all vigilant against it so
just to be clear cursed Armour has asked
Rebecca long bay to step down it doesn't
as you say whether she's agreed to step
down but though I presume it's been
mutually agreed but a significant
development within the power structure
and the balance of power within Kirsten
as Shadow Kavanagh because Rebecca long
Bailey obviously one of the most
significant left-wing figures within it
I think we can go to our chief political
correspondent John Craig now who was
scheduled to talk about another story
affecting the Tories but instead I think
John will talk about this strong action
by Kia stahma
yes Rebecca long Bailey who of course
stood for the Labour leadership against
cast Armour was seen very much of the as
the pro Jeremy Corbyn candidate well she
has committed what Jeremy clearly mr.
saki-sama regards as something that's
completely beyond the pale unacceptable
now this is all to do with as the as the
spokesman for Kirsten Mar says she an
article she an article Rebecca shared
earlier today containing an anti-semitic
conspiracy theory now my understanding
is that she shared something from the
actor at Maxine Peake to do with a
conspiracy theory about Israeli Secret
Service or soldiers
training a US police in the way of the
the kneeling on the neck of suspects in
the way that George Floyd was killed in
America but clearly Sakia has wasted no
time in acting now of course this as
you've said Colleen has big
ramifications because of course it means
that someone who is very close to the
education unions at a time when Sakia
keeps being taunted at Prime Minister's
Questions by Boris Johnson about
Labour's support for the education
unions in their opposition are getting
children back to school
she's been removed and/or it's probably
quite likely that sakir will want to
replace Rebecca long bailey with someone
who perhaps is more as some people in
the labour party might say more
mainstream rather than the left-wing
figure but this has come right out of
the blue this story because I think many
people at Westminster probably were not
even aware that Rebecca long bailey had
done what she'd done
clearly [ __ ] mr. sakir who has right at
the beginning of his labour leadership
when he was elected leader on the 4th of
april he said straightaway I want to
apologise to the Jewish community for
anti-semitism and here we have probably
the most senior left winger left in the
shadow cabinet sacked pretty
unceremoniously pretty swiftly pretty
abruptly for action which mr. sakir as
regarded as anti-semitic and no doubt
Rebecca long Bailey supporters on the
Left will be cross about this be pretty
angry about it but sukhiya has shown
that he is not going to tolerate any
action from any politician in the labour
party no matter how senior if it is
deemed to be action or words or support
for anything anti-semitic so this is a
big development it may well mean and
altering of the balance of the shadow
cabinet I think it's probably pretty
unlikely that another left winger will
get that education job now at
hijab when sakir defeated Rebecca long
Bailey education was seen as quite a
respectable middle-ranking post in the
shadow cabin it was previously done by
Angela Reina who of course is now deputy
leader and now of course he has a chance
if he wants to to bring in a figure as
who probably more loyal to him and not
to replace her with another left winger
pretty unlikely if he does replace
Rebecca long bailey with another left
winger but she has paid the price for
what is deemed to be anti-semitic
conduct will she be a left-wing
troublemaker on the back benches
potentially yes because we already know
that there are the likes of Richard
Bergen mr. Corbyn himself
Ian Lavery who are probably not very
happy with the way mr. sakir is taking
the Labor Party the direction he's
taking it but now right out of the blue
suddenly his first big decision if you
like on personnel he has some will say
ruthlessly sacked his main leadership
rival Rebecca long Bailey but plenty
equally there'll be plenty of Labour MPs
who will applaud this and say he's done
absolutely the right thing John I'll
just read you actually the the tweet
because this is very much conversation
that's been conducted via Twitter as you
say she referenced the article five
hours ago two hours ago she added this
and this is her most recent Twitter they
go i retweeted Maxine Peaks article
basing peak the the actor because of her
significant achievements and because the
thrust of her argument is to stay in the
Labor Party wasn't intended to be an
endorsement of all aspects of the
article that's timed as being posted two
hours ago so whether that's post the
news that she has been ditched from the
shadow